and that's it that's the whole orgasm
she hears him off like in the bathroom
dude mads Mickelson or whatever that guy
yeah what about him I love him man he
was in a [ __ ] comedy movie I looked
at the other day so far in a comedy
movie yeah what's in a comedy movie I
looked at yeah like an old lady says it
seriously I looked at one of my programs
was it the drinking movie yep no I don't
know what's that well I don't know
what's the movie you saw oh not the
drinking movie no uh it was a foreign
movie oh okay well he's farming what's
the name of the movie I don't know
okay well that you brought up something
that we can't even discuss no we can't
but I do love mads he's another guy
who's funny and he doesn't seem like he
is yeah that's true he was on a flight
once he also he also commits
so hard to the roles that he's playing I
know like he's in that [ __ ] movie uh
that Nicholas winding record movie that
nobody saw uh the ones in black and
white
he plays like a crazy crazy Viking and
he uh uh uh anyway he's just like it's
like the bloodiest [ __ ] movie ever uh
what the [ __ ] is that in that movie dude
uh Rio
read out the cartoon yeah yeah no Ice
Age Ice Age yeah so um no but I I saw he
was on a plane of mine oh he was on a
plane with me and he he was sitting like
maybe one behind me and I would I I
would look back and like that's the
[ __ ] guy and then I didn't really
know his name you know it was like years
ago I was like that's a [ __ ] guy
that's a bad guy in the James Bond movie
all right yeah yeah he was reading a
script and he was just like reading the
script like this and the light was on it
I mean it was so cinematic because at
nighttime flight and he was just like
turning it over and I was like he's so I
mean maybe this is [ __ ] me but like
you know succumbing to Hollywood but I
was like dude he's so an evil villain
yeah he's yeah totally I mean he's a
great actor he got huge he was always a
popular actor but he what made him huge
is that show he was on was playing
Hannibal Lecter oh yeah that's right
playing Hannibal Lecter probably such a
goofy show but yeah also was he the lead
of the [ __ ] Pusher movies is that his
like first [ __ ] I don't know what that
is uh all right well since nobody knows
anything in his I mean this is literally
yeah
we show him on the screen right now and
they'd be like oh yeah that guy
true he's super super
handsome in a weird way how much money
has sex dude it's so quick Valhalla
Rising and this is how he has an orgasm
he goes a kiss
and that's it that's the whole orgasm
that's the whole orgasm but then and in
a few minutes like in the shower whoever
he had sex with hears him with the door
closed she hears him off like in the
bathroom just go
okay what's he doing he's just like
getting the energy out
just like that's ridiculous dude
[Music]